Speaker 1: Yesterday, I played a clip for
you from radical Republican Congresswoman
Marjorie Taylor Green's off the wall interview
with Alex Jones.
That's the same Alex Jones, who said, Thank
God, you're not David Pakman.
Speaker 3: Thank your lucky stars every day.
You're not David Pakman.
Speaker 1: Exactly.
That's the same Alex Jones, who now has attacked
our bonus show.
Speaker 3: Oh, the bonus show where you want
to make money and everybody else that makes
money to fund themselves is bad.
Speaker 1: OK.
So during that interview, I didn't see this
clip until after yesterday's show during that
very same interview with Marjorie Taylor Greene.
Alex Jones actually suggests to Marjorie Taylor
Greene, What about you running for president?
And Marjorie Taylor Greene doesn't say, I'm
not interested.
Take a look at this.
Speaker 3: Can we get you to run for president
in the next few years?
Because I think I think you're one of the
few people that would probably have a better
voting record and have a better chance at
winning than even Trump or maybe a green DeSantis
ticket?
Speaker 2: Oh my God.
Speaker 4: Well, Alex, I don't know what's
going to happen.
I'm I'm a very strong supporter of President
Trump, but in the future, we'll we'll definitely
see what
Speaker 1: happens by the way that's code
for.
I would absolutely do it, but I'm not going
to run against Trump and
Speaker 4: what the people think about something
like that.
Speaker 3: But we need a green agenda to build
back better with President Green.
Speaker 4: Yeah.
Well, with my agenda would be all for this
country.
I just I love our country and I hate absolutely
hate what the federal government has done
to the American people.
Sure, I've seen
Speaker 3: before, CNN spends that I'm not
actually endorsing their fake green agenda,
their comments agenda.
It's a play on words.
Speaker 1: Yes, it's a play on words.
Now, laugh at your own peril.
Laugh at your own peril because many of us
laughed off Trump.
But you know why we did?
Because we overestimated the intelligence
and common sense and critical thinking skills
of the Republican electorate.
We overstated it.
And if you overestimate the intelligence of
the Republican voter, you get burned.
And so if you laugh at the idea of Marjorie
Taylor Greene as at least as the Republican
nominee, just remember that Donald Trump did
it.
Now we almost have to hope.
This is crazy.
We have to hope that Republicans on principle
would not elect a woman president, but sadly,
this is exactly the type of woman they might
elect.
She can be there proof about how wrong we
are about their sexism and misogyny and the
entire thing.
And I hate to say this, but most likely.
Whoever replaces Trump as the Republican front
runner, if Trump is pushed out, if Trump doesn't
run, it's a different thing.
But if Trump is pushed out, it will probably
be someone who's even worse than Trump.
And I know that it's hard to imagine.
But when the party is so radical and 50 60
percent of its voters are so whacked out,
they still want Trump to run at this point
in time.
They're not going to say, let's choose someone
more rational and sober than Donald Trump.
If anything, it would go in the opposite direction
and in particular when policy no longer matters.
And a very high priority for these folks is
pick someone that will trigger the liberals.
That's that's a top priority for who they
pick.
It's certainly plausible they would go with
somebody like Marjorie Taylor Greene if it
came to it.
I mean, remember, evangelicals didn't care
about how obviously non-religious Trump was
and how he didn't go to church.
And he was pro-choice until he decided to
run for president and all this stuff.
And eventually, the evangelicals came over
and supported Donald Trump, the family values.
People didn't care about the number of wives
and divorces and affairs that Donald Trump
they eventually came to came over.
And part of it was, we don't like Hillary,
obviously.
And part of it was, let's trigger the liberals.
They would be so triggered by this.
So I would not laugh off the possibility not
of a Marjorie Taylor Greene presidency.
Although once you get to be the nominee, anything
can happen, as we saw in 2016.
But I would not laugh off the possibility
of a Marjorie Taylor Greene nomination among
the Republican Party.
Let me know what you think.
Find me on Twitter at De Packman.
We'll take a quick break and be back.
What a Friday show we have for you today.
Welcome back to the show, remember that the
David Pakman show does depend on viewers and
listeners like you to support us through the
membership program.
Alex Jones has now attacked the membership
program.
He has disparaged the bonus show and so we
need to fight Alex Jones and say no, he will
not restrict membership.
He will not restrict the bonus show.
You can sign up at Join Pacman Dot Com and
you can use the coupon code.
Wow.
Twenty two to get a sizable discount.